foreign
so one thing we know about our friends
over at reason which is the libertarian
publication is that they are very
concerned about moral panics they want
to make sure that nobody is engaging in
a moral Panic it's just that to them
anyone who demonstrates any moral
concern over any issue at all
is automatically guilty of a moral panic
it is impossible to make a moral
argument of any kind about anything
without being charged with a moral Panic
from people like this
unless you're having a moral Panic about
moral panics in which case it's not a
moral panic
so those are the rules they don't make
any sense but those are the rules and
that brings us to an article published
by reason shortly before the new year
written by Scott shackford entitled
the fight over kids at drag shows is a
classic moral panic
shackford writes quote of course Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and his
administration would contribute to the
latest Christmas-themed targeting of
drag queens as some existential threats
the state Department's uh the the
State's Department of Business and
Professional Regulation sent a letter
Wednesday to the Orlando Philharmonic
Plaza foundation in Orlando Florida
because their venue was hosting a drag
queen Christmas which is a touring Stage
production crossing the country that's
been around for eight years the letter
warns that the venue that they they have
reason to believe that this drag show is
of a sexual nature involving the
exposure or exhibit or exhibition of
sexual organs simulated sexual activity
and or the sexualization of children's
stories
note that this letter doesn't actually
say that there is any nudity or
simulated sexual activity at the show
only the department believes that there
is it probably consulted this Twitter
thread by Taylor Hansen who provides
images and clips of the show from its
stop in Austin Texas
a drag queen Christmas is a pretty
raunchy show in the way that's familiar
to anybody who has watched drag
performances but the only nudity found
in Hanson's clips and images is a pair
of absolutely fake boobs being worn by a
drag queen there's a lot of overtly
sexualized behavior and gyrating from
people who are not actually naked or
having sex
ah so you see
shackford is offering important context
here the male cross-dresser was only
flaunting prosthetic breasts in front of
small children not real ones
and although there was lots of
sexualized behavior as he says None of
the performers were fully naked and
besides they were only simulating sex in
front of children they weren't actually
having sex
now how does this make any of it okay
well because shackford can compare this
thing to some other thing and we all
know if you can compare one thing to
another thing then the thing must be
fine this is internet debating 101 here
okay he continues essentially this is a
Madonna concert Circa her Blonde
Ambition World Tour days but Don of
course is famously beloved by gay men
and drag queens in particular for her
wild looks and deliberately sexualized
Persona she was threatened with arrest
in Toronto back in 1990 for simulating
masturbation during her live performance
of like a virgin though police
eventually backed down there was a moral
Panic then that children exposed to
Madonna's Antics were being sexualized
at a young age funny how some things
don't change
now
there are so many egregiously stupid
arguments in this piece that I don't
want to get hung up on any one of them
for too long but I do need to take a
moment to let this part absorb because
this is a classic move of child
sexualization apologists otherwise known
as groomers
they love to point out that kids in
earlier decades were exposed to sexual
content too and uh well look how well
they turned out
except that the astute Observer might
note that those kids in fact
did not turn out well
indeed the people who were having a
moral Panic about Madonna in the 80s and
90s claiming that the coarsening of
culture the over sexualization the
profanity and debauchery would put us on
a slippery slope into full-on cultural
depravity
they were 100 percent right
they didn't even know how right they
were
even they couldn't imagine that in
another 30 years there would be
family-friendly drag shows with
cross-dressing half-naked men simulating
anal sex in front of toddlers
so critics three decades ago they were
not engaged in a panic but rather were
issuing a prophetic warning about the
state of and direction of the culture
a warning that the Scott shackfords of
the world world have always been quick
to blow off because the Scott shackfords
of the world are always wrong about
everything
back to the article the the wrong man
writes quote if I had small children I
probably would not take them to the show
but what's clear from Hanson's clip is
that several parents did voluntarily and
seem to know that this was going to
happen it doesn't appear that there's
actual nudity in the show and the amount
of sexualization would put it at maybe
an R rating if it were in a movie movie
what we have here is a lot of screaming
and politicization about families making
entertainment decisions other adults do
not like
this is flat out a moral panic and a few
lines later he continues
but this is not a moral Panic some
insist there is a limit to the parents
rights argument and this this all
crosses a line parents should not be
allowed to take their kids to live drag
shows to that I say by looking at the
behavior here in the public response to
it we can see that just as with Madonna
this is a moral panic
well at least we can all agree that
Scott whatever else you might say about
him is a tremendous and persuasive
writer
this is a moral Panic some people say
it's not a moral Panic to that I say
this is a moral panic
truly a compelling composition I have to
say he concludes quote claiming that
drag shows are different is a subjective
evaluation based on how a person feels
about exposure to drag performances it's
an attempt to force one group of
people's parental choices on the
collective and the Mindless tossing
around of the word groomer is just an
epithet designed to shut down opposition
on the belief that nobody wants to be
accused of supporting child sexual abuse
it's a reminder of back during the 1970s
through the 1990s When anybody who was
not heterosexual was regularly accused
of trying to recruit kids moral panics
about gay people interacting with
children are hardly new we have laws
about minors and nudity and sexually
explicit live performances and we have
parents to make decisions for stuff that
falls just on the legal side of that
line that's how it has been for the
longest of times and drag queens don't
change that calculus if you don't want
your children to see this stuff don't
take them leave everybody else alone
so once again we have the historical
comparison that only helps to validate
the very concerns he's trying to dismiss
because he points out that a few decades
ago
some people were concerned that the gay
agenda was recruiting kids
okay fast forward to our current time
and we see that LGBT identification
doubled in the millennial generation and
then doubled again for Gen Z
so all of the evidence strongly suggests
that the recruitment efforts were not
only real but incredibly effective and
still ongoing
so what is shackford's actual argument
well
there really isn't anything in this
lengthy diatribe that deserves to be
dignified with the label of argument but
the closest he gets is when he points
out repeatedly that parents make the
decision to bring their kids to drag
shows it's an it's an entertainment
Choice as he says
if you don't want your own kids to be
spectators at a drag themed sex show
then don't bring them
leave those other parents alone
this is what passes for an argument
among Libertarians simply pointing out
that something is a choice is automatic
justification of the choice
a choice is valid because it was chosen
they think
but that is completely incoherent of
course
yes we all recognize that some parents
choose to expose their children to this
sort of sexual content yes that that's
established
but the question is not about whether
it's a choice but rather about the
nature of the choice
and in this case they are making the
choice to subject their children to
sexual grooming
that is not a valid choice
it's not a morally acceptable Choice it
should not be a legally permissible
choice
and when it comes to drag shows by the
way Choice only works as an excuse if
we're talking about the choice that
adults make to expose themselves to such
content
okay so we're talking about adults at a
drag show
then it might be good enough to just say
well all the people here chose to be
here and this is what they want to see
now even that argument is not decisive I
don't think
because just because people choose to do
something doesn't make it automatically
okay there's still a conversation to be
had
but but the point is that here we're
talking about the choice
that adults make to expose another party
another person a child to this content
it is a choice being made for and on
behalf of somebody else
and that someone else cannot legally
consent to being involved in this
activity
so so this is not actually a question of
personal choice at all this is the the
the person that issue the child cannot
choose
the child therefore does not choose to
be at the drag show
so the drag show is something that
happens to the child it's being done to
him he is brought there against his will
he's exposed to these images and ideas
against his will
because again even if the child says
yeah I want to go
he's a child he can't consent
the question then is whether parents
have the right
to do whatever they want to their kids
and whether this right supersedes the
child's right to be protected from harm
and only a moral idiot and a pervert
would answer yes to a question like that
which explains Scott shackford's
position on the subject
and that is why he is
today first one of the Year canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]